[Applause]
this is Justin hey wolde reading Matt
Paget's review for NBA 2k 17 - Caze NBA
games are known for smooth fluid play
and NBA 2k 17 stays true to form the
game's controls make complex moves
accessible and once you grow accustomed
to the potential of your fingertips NBA
2k 17 feels like a game of instincts
rather than a calculated series of
inputs of course victory wouldn't feel
as sweet if the AI didn't put up a good
fight the AI isn't going to fall for the
same trick every time so mixing up your
strategies is required passing the ball
to your best player in an attempt to
score three points every time just isn't
going to work finding out the best way
to tackle each shift is what keeps the
game engaging hurry is inside he's
covered by Rondo and count it to get
your bearings on the court you can jump
into the 2k u mode where you participate
in scrimmage games that feed you
tutorial tips as you play gameplay
pauses as instructions and narration pop
up to let you know how to pass shoot and
retrieve the ball on defense this can be
helpful for learning the basics but it
would be a lot more effective if the
game reacted to your performance and
coached you appropriately rather than
merely providing static direction when
it's game time NBA 2k 17s commentators
camera angles and mid game events such
as mascot antics and halftime dunk shows
demonstrate incredible realism and
attention to detail the only downside to
the whole broadcast setup is the pregame
and halftime shows they sound good but
the virtual hosts are stiff it often
looks like someone's pulling the strings
of realistic Ernie Johnson Shaquille
O'Neal and Kenny Smith puppets he gets
it done every night it's like where it's
like we're watching a video game when we
watch this tablet and I've never seen a
video game actually play basketball it's
amazing playing with authentic teams and
players scratches the NBA itch but my
career offers a different kind of game
where you create a player and master a
single position as you make your way
through college and into the league
playing as a single athlete can feel
restrictive in some sports games but
playing your part on a team in NBA 2k 7
tene is consistently engaging and
rewarding my career features a story
that follows you a player who gets
nicknamed the President or the Prez as
you ascend to pro status cutscenes are
infrequent but they had some nice
background to you and your life through
moments of playing video games with a
friend or talking to your excited caring
mom over the phone
uh yeah I got it mom but uh grant got
most of it oh and tell her I love her I
love you baby
Oh mom that's cold and you can improve
your game by participating in practices
these are minigames of sorts that occur
when you go to the team's practice court
most of these challenges are fun making
the choice to go to the gym before a
game a lot easier outside of playing
basketball
my career encourages you to take part in
life off the court you can attend
promotional and fan events to get a
little extra currency to spend on
attributes upgrades and more for your
player but these amount to nothing more
than selecting a menu item watching your
player walk out the door and then
getting a message saying you completed
the event the lack of interactivity with
these events is fine but the amount of
time it takes for this process to finish
feels a bit excessive however you do get
text messages from friends players and
coaches these moments of texting are
often funny and add a bit of life in
between games and practices that's much
appreciated
2k 17 offers a number of modes to play
online against other players and for the
most part the connection holds up well
you can compete against other players in
the basic play now mode or take a team
you assemble through card packs and face
off against others in my team in this
mode you kick things off with a starter
pack that gives you a small bounty of
cards to help you build a lineup of
players in addition to paying real money
for these packs you can earn them by
racking up in-game currency however this
process takes much longer and you aren't
guaranteed to get any useful cards in a
pack this can be frustrating especially
when you pay real money toward the
purchase of card packs but you're
probably better off buying the players
you want from the auction house anyway
doing what essentially amounts to
gambling is a risk that just isn't worth
it
despite these few drawbacks though NBA
2k 17s excitement is contagious the
available modes and gameplay are
fantastic and it makes playing the game
as much of a joy as being in the thick
of it's wonderful presentations with a
clear path Abajo
I'm the dunk by Payton and just amazing
awareness there